una reunión para recordar a los muertos
en kale se celebraron vigilias después
de que al menos 27 inmigrantes se
ahogaran en el canal de la mancha tras
el incidente boris johnson escribió a su
homólogo francés exponiendo su plan de
acción y sugiriendo que los migrantes
que lleguen con éxito a reino unido sean
devueltos a francia si se devolviera
rápidamente a los que llegan a este país
se reduciría significativamente el
incentivo para que la gente ponga su
vida en manos de los traficantes este
sería el mayor paso que podríamos dar
juntos para reducir la atracción hacia
el norte de francia y romper el modelo
de negocio de las bandas criminales las
otras propuestas del plan del primer
ministro británico son considerar a la
posibilidad de realizar patrullas
conjuntas en barco incrementar el uso de
la tecnología incluyendo sensores y
radares patrullas recíprocamente por
aire y reforzar el intercambio de
inteligencia pero las relaciones
franco-británicas están en un punto
difícil tras cinco años de negociaciones
sobre el presi y el reciente
enfrentamiento por los derechos de pesca
su parte el presidente de francia está
molesto por el manejo de la situación
del ejecutivo británico
de
contenidos me sorprende que no se hagan
las cosas con seriedad como líderes no
nos comunicamos sobre estos temas a
través de tweets o cartas publicadas no
somos chivatos los ministros trabajan
con seriedad para resolver un asunto
serio con gente seria de serbios mong
lin cuestión serios de rendición salió
el ministro francés de interior del
daymán canceló el viernes las
conversaciones con su homóloga británica
pretty battle como protesta en contra de
una carta pública sobre la crisis de los
migrantes de boris johnson